recently leftists won landslide
elections in Argentina and
left-of-centre candidates won ki mayoral
posts in Colombia for all its faults
democracy works in Latin America but
fair elections weren't good enough for
Bolivia's leftist President Evo Morales
who was caught trying to steal an
illegal fourth term and had to flee the
country when the army sided with
pro-democracy protesters in Ecuador and
Chile left us if tried to oust
democratically elected leaders using mob
violence the rampage continues in Chile
despite the president's decision to
reverse unpopular transit fare hikes and
to increase social spending it's clear
that Latin America's leftists want power
by any means necessary in Bolivia and
Ecuador
authorities suspect Cuban subversion the
narco regime in Venezuela and the narco
dictatorship in Cuba have the motive and
the means to attack the rule of law
democracy and free market policies and
that's exactly what they'll do as long
as democratic governments let them act
with impunity to Latin American
democracies confront mob violence let us
know in our poll and let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI